so you talked about the three wells in
your book how does someone know which
well they should tap into for their
story so it's a good question I can very
quickly show a quickly explain the three
wells so you can see what they are and
it's a very simple concept it's and it's
linked to meditation would be spoken
about before is when I slow down the
moment of creativity so if I'm writing
and there's that flashing cursor and I'm
seeing that flashing cursor in front of
me you know were you writing on your
document and I can draw from three
distinct sources within myself in that
moment of creation the first is are the
movies that I've seen or anything that
I've read books that I've read any media
that I've consumed that is not that I
haven't created I call that the external
source as well then the other one I can
tap into is the imagination well which
feels like a lightning bolt from above
it's just imagination I just make it up
feels like I've made it up feels like
it's come out of nowhere and that's the
imagination well and then the third well
is the memory well which is my own deep
memories that I can tap into but it's
difficult to go there sometimes but
they're mine they're like my lived
experiences all my senses were alive
when I experienced whatever it was that
I've experienced and so those are the
three different wells and when we write
we just automatically tap into whichever
one when we're writing it depends on who
we are depends on what we're writing so
if I say to you now very quickly I will
just try and do this experiment and
imagine a scene set in a cemetery or
graveyard and you have to imagine some
images that come to your mind
chances are the first thing that you
imagine or from external sources well
green grasses headstones priests
standing with a little Bible it's
raining maybe it's raining maybe they
were umbrellas do all this stuff that
isn't an external source when we write
we often write that's the first thing we
write it's very easy to access and very
good if you're writing to a deadline to
write to the external source as well the
imagination while is a bit more tricky
if I say imagine a scene said in the
graveyard that you've never seen before
it becomes a bit of a wait a minute or
something happens there that you'd never
imagined before then it becomes more
difficult
but sometimes you can have an idea it's
a ha and then you write the little and
your imagination just kind of flies or
if I say imagine a cemetery that you've
been to that you've experienced or
something that you've seen in the
cemetery and then you have to kind of
slow your life down it's more difficult
to access that but then you can
sometimes draw from that and you'll find
really interesting stuff there so when
we're writing unconsciously when I write
unconsciously I'm very often tapping
into the external source as well I'm
writing movies that have existed before
and maybe imagining stuff up but I'm not
putting any bit of me in it because it's
difficult to do that for me some people
by the way just not right from the
memory wall immediately and they just
stack their own you write stories that
then that they've experienced and then
they still sometimes they write stories
that are so much in their memory wall
that they're boring and they need to
start tapping into the external source
as well and write you know draw from
some other movies draw a structure from
other movies or scenes or something and
imagine a bit more to make your story
but more so it doesn't there's no real
clear distinction as to which well you
should tap into when you write it
depends what you're writing it depends
what stage you are at writing it I have
a personal preference for the memory
well because I believe that's where a
lot of authenticity and resonance
comes in and I think even if you're
writing a slasher horror movie and
you've gone mostly from so that horror
movie I wrote was basically The Hills
Have Eyes which was a old movie they
redid it recently was that mixed with
some personal experiences that I've had
but if you're adding a slasher movie you
may not have to draw from your memory
well that much but maybe if you've
written something and you've really
written it and you want to pump it up a
bit go to each scene and even think of
the location and then draw from your own
memory and say wait I have not been in a
location like that or similar to that
and what was my experience there what
stayed with me in my memory and you put
that into your scene it can be something
small like the sound of cicadas or
something just put it in your scene
suddenly it's like it's alive because
you remember that from your actual lived
experience and then suddenly you can
make a scene that is a bland scene
really really resonant so yeah that's
where so it depends on which well you
want to tap into at which time depending
what you're writing I know that when my
publisher first asked me to Horace it
can you not have a graph that says I
keep you riding a slashing our baby's
gotta be eighty percent external source
as well
ten percent imagination and ten percent
memory I'm like well not really I'd love
to be able to say that but that's not
really the way it works the creative
process is a lot more organic so much so
that when you write and you might not be
consciously aware of what while you're
tapping into and then only when you
rewrite you might say wait a minute I've
just copied all other movies yeah
can I put something else in oh this is
just my story no one's gonna relate to
it how can I find other stories and put
maybe be inspired by the structural
characters from other stories and put
them into my story so yeah it's a it's a
difficult question to answer because
there's not just one well that you have
to tap into at a time with all three
happening at once and you can pump your
story up by suddenly being more
imaginative
you know you've set your scene the other
way do you imagine maybe it's somewhere
else play be like a child you know just
play and imagine forget my scene is set
in the living room but could it be set
in a I don't know like a rollercoaster
ride maybe and then tribe doesn't work
oh good work but at least you were using
your imagination for a while
some living rooms are like rollercoaster
rides what's going on